the next few days and weeks in Ukraine
are likely to be a picture of confusion
with different messaging about who's
advancing where now there are two likely
strategic aims for Ukraine firstly to
reclaim the donbass the Russians said
that that's what they wanted to take so
obviously the ukrainians will want to
throw the Russians out of the the dombas
if they can but the second aim is really
to break the land bridge this this
bridge between the donbass and Crimea
that land bridge is really important to
the Russians but it's pretty important
to the ukrainians because if they can
drive south from zapparesia the area
that includes the zapariesian nuclear
power station to Melita Paul on the
coast then they'll break that land
bridge clean apart and so that sort of
area presents lots of challenges to the
ukrainians but also some advantages
because the ground there is is easier to
work with it's probably better ground
for main battle tanks and some of the
heavy armor but let's have a look at a
particular area let's just have a look
at at one place Top Mac
um in this in this part of the world
there is a satellite image of top Mac
now if you look very carefully you can
see like scratches on it those scratches
these are the trenches that the Russians
have already built but put on there the
real trenches that we know the Russians
have got that we've identified then add
to it the rivers in the area then add to
it The High Ground in the area that's
really important to any commander you've
got to seize The High Ground and hold it
and if you're defending you've got to
prevent yourself losing The High Ground
that's really important and so any
commander that's trying to take that
area has got to think about the
obstacles the altitude the water and
where the enemy are now the weather at
the moment is very good for the
ukrainians uh there's no rain in the
forecast for the next two or three weeks
the temperature is rising it's 20
degrees now it's going to go to about 25
degrees that means the ground is drying
out quickly and that's good for tanks
tanks 70-ton Vehicles they need dry
ground to be able to spread out
and so as the ukrainians come to meet
these sorts of obstacles let's just have
a look at them in a bit more detail
Dragon's Teeth these things that are
placed on the ground Angie tank traps
things to slow the tanks down to make it
difficult for vehicles and tanks and
some of the support vehicles to get
across these dragon teeth in themselves
are not no great shakes but if they're
covered by fire if the enemy has gotten
zeroed in on the on their artillery if
they've got the Infantry covering it
with fire then they can be a very
expensive way of getting across the land
for an attacker getting through Dragon's
Teeth getting over trenches having to
lay bridges over the water all those
things slow you down they Bunch up your
forces and that presents easy targets
for the defending side and so is each
Commander one attacking one defending as
they try to achieve their objectives
it's like a sort of multi-dimensional
game of chess between both of them
making the best use of the ground the
height the vehicles the men the
Firepower that they've got and we'll see
these complex chess games going on
between commands on both sides
everywhere around front that the
ukrainians try to break through in this
offensive